[Music]
in double the limit news
submitted by Arthur Baker hello I
remember ml now Twitter has announced
they are testing double limit tweets
that's 280 characters it's about time
is Twitter still yes I've been waiting
for them because like a lot of people
have to screen cap and then upload that
as a picture why are they feeling
threatened or something that there's
like [ __ ] we got a double is now people
just been complaining myself ya know
I've been complaining this thought and
I'm like writing and it's like oh I got
a delete delete delete delete and I
gotta find ways to shorten words and
it's like just let me [ __ ] write and
then right and then right you know there
used to be what it was like twit longer
or something like that where if you went
over it but the reason why they're doing
it is because they're saying that in
almost all the languages you need a lot
more characters to express an idea duh
no [ __ ]
so no so like languages like Japanese
Korean and Chinese you can convey the
exact same message with way less
characters so they're just more
characters one word yeah Korean though I
don't I don't know but they were just
saying that for English especially like
with English you you need way more
characters to convey a thought cuz it's
just it's so wordy yeah there's all like
the grammatical stuff like a of about
like all those things we got like six
syllable words yeah so like here's an
example of a tweet this one right here
so this is with 140 characters that
we've always had and this is with 280 so
you can see the difference is like how
much more you can fit
and then you can also convey the same
thought with way less characters pose in
depth the Japanese or Chinese or Korea
what are you trying to convey I guess to
play devil's advocate or to flip the
script on people like that so all of us
here we know we don't like tweet dumb
[ __ ] right like we're not tweeting about
how we hate our co-workers or oh my god
the new [ __ ] iPhone 8 and like we're
not talking about dumb [ __ ] like that
are you calling people that do that dumb
[ __ ] though uh when they complain about
[ __ ] does it matter
like first yeah I don't I don't want to
[ __ ] see your vet [ __ ] the best
you know that's what I use it for you
know what's wrong with the world but his
are valid and and they're like and and
they make they give you like it's like
either moral point but there's like a
philosophical point to it so it makes
sense not like I don't know I probably
so people I need to go on Twitter more
so for us we're like damn we need more
character so we can really convey our
thoughts or whatever but what about
those people that [ __ ] have vent fest
it's like isn't it good that they're
limited because that's what a lot of
people are saying the first person
everyone's thinking about what this is
our president like how he's constantly
tweeting and like he's like on the preak
of really behind this thing then he's
like giving more workers I tell you what
I last tweeted the argument makes sense
but at the same time it's like that
person could just tweet a lot of tweets
like that's it you can't stop them from
saying a bunch of stuff yeah but there's
more efforts and I was like [ __ ] like
now I got it don't stop them people
people read and retweet threads now and
it's like 30 tweets 30 treats at a
hundred and forty characters each you
know 30 minutes to think yeah most of
mine are Instagram posts and retweets I
don't have any a payment right now yeah
and then the last thing I
I tweeted was like at a company because
you know they needed to resolve an issue
the very last one was on August 24th
when I see almost naked girls on insta
with CEO on their bio they never say
what company like golf supply or
mouthwash what do you guys
then that was your home $3 Mike tweet I
cover the important things the things
that matter in this world why are there
so many hot models that are half-naked
with CEO on their bio I need to know
what company it's the company of theirs
their bodies yeah themselves why don't
they just say hooker I personally
wouldn't have mine 140 more characters
of wherever that was going here's like
an example so the exact same message
said in English Spanish and Japanese so
for English it's 140 characters Spanish
154 and people love talking like there's
a lot of words you have to put together
to like Spanish generally longer like
more letters involved with each word I
don't know anything Spanish Mexican you
just always look that way don't even
make eye contact she's mix mix if pedia
Mexican yeah Mex appear like an
encyclopedia but like a Mexican mix it
pedia yeah we don't know anything you
were born here why do I always think you
ordered Mexican see we have the same
revelation like every time I hear I
think you're the Mexican ambassador but
I'm more like Chicana
you know what I mean like I think that's
our difference it's true I'm like the
[ __ ] whatever you but you did live in
Mexico for a year that's why I'm here Oh
cuz you keep telling me you're Mexico
stories I only live there for one year
announced 15 stories except for party
crew that actually matters a lot like if
someone says hey I lived in I lived in
Taiwan for a year when I was three the
people I just erase that from your
record cannot remember [ __ ] but if
you're like I live until I want freedom
I was twenty five your pilot oh this one
knows all the local spots and all the
food
you tell me about your Mexican rave days
while your your family's collection of
body parts inside of a couch or laughs
it was like gross things like like
boogers or something oh that was my
cousin that she lived here he's just
born here that was what happened in
Mexico really happened here oh my god my
cousin we she got her period she was so
gross
she was like stuffing her used period
yeah that's know she thought we would
never find out she needed to save it for
later
easy right now he probably sees you with
the [ __ ] so [ __ ] everyone's like
the most racist character like when I
see them and what am i I do yeah
huh then what am I like the Macdonald
eyebrow I mean you only have your hoodie
on you know you're halfway there
yeah Bart Casey have different different
silk robes on oh my god we have our
hands together like this yeah the
Compton Rick because he's like a member
of NWA 1990 Compton thug it's cuz she
lives like on the other side of Compton
Iran we always talk about this barbecue
restaurant that I always tell them the
gone because it's on the same street
have you been gone yeah
we closed it no they they open one in
like a nice Oh West Hollywood right I
think that doesn't taste the same
I thought they expanded it anyway oh
they did yeah
they bought the next unit next door they
expanded all the way through yeah they
did I don't know anyways Twitter yeah do
you think Twitter is doing this so that
they can compete more with Instagram and
Facebook like do you think they've kind
of dropped in like the in the in the
sphere of I think that social media
there's super-killer it's a little
Germany Oh scuse Mike who's my numbers
on the Twitter don't grow
weight though I know you when I came
back yeah nope those people did I just
do it like once every three months
people use their instagrams the same way
we use like different forms of
communication like phone email texting
so when they want instant information or
get it out of there everyone goes to
Twitter or something happens you know
[ __ ] was that an earthquake then you go
to Twitter and like oh yeah that was I
go on Instagram I wait for someone up
I'll take a picture of the earthquake
which is a filter a heartfelt caption I
got all of this bitter earthquake we use
the stories more than the pictures not
only use stories for brand deals and
promotions he's got his own [ __ ] he's
eyes on
I think majority of my insta stories is
just my dog I never do [ __ ] like besides
all look at the face of my dog that's it
and it's like one every two weeks what
about your Twitter do you ever tweet
yeah like what month ago I tweet on the
24th everything else is like Instagram
posts or retweets of other people how do
I respond more than I tweet verified
recently on Twitter yeah lucky oh yeah
how did you do it did you ask yeah why'd
you do it so we can all do it yeah yeah
yeah you just ask who do you ask our
network okay and then it's evil no cuz
then the network has to get you so you
have to get you approved so he got to
kind
yeah how come he got decline I don't
know they don't what I look at him
saying I don't like Bart maybe the last
time I logged it was part like four or
five years ago oh maybe that's why no
but less time when I was asking for JK
to give everybody they were saying that
they don't verify accounts unless
there's multiple accounts trying to be
that person that was a long time ago now
it's like a weird thing they want you to
have it a certain way like your banner
has to be a certain way saying what you
are who you are you don't ever watch it
I don't know they didn't improve so
brain I never I never cared I never
wanted it but then I seen like people
with 6,000 followers getting all right
let me do this and they were like now I
think about getting verified and so I
saw that and I'm like [ __ ] might as well
it gives you more pool I still don't
care about getting verify should I care
about me you should cuz then you're
verified what does that even mean though
I just want that blue checkmark yeah it
makes me feel like I'm special and
official at first it was just that but
now it's better for business because
when you do anything it shows up for
people like you know if you have people
have their notifications set for like
people they follow whatever if your
verified and you say something to them
it shows up on their phone just because
you're barefoot you know what the cool
thing about Twitter though is like they
don't censor like the way Instagram does
so if you want to see full nude all that
stuff bad words or just like crazy yeah
like that's you is it still like that
snap I had yeah unless somebody reports
it I don't go on but these porn but I
keep falling and and like tweeting at me
saying like oh I made this video for you
and then it's like our jakey news video
and then you keep watching and it's porn
and I'm like what the [ __ ]
and art they don't click those an art
piece you know I didn't click on it it
was like a video that they sent like be
tweeted at me how come I never get those
no I look
their page and they sent it to all of us
all your engines well maybe I don't care
but um what did they do they they they
have these fake porn accounts right and
then they use these accounts to like
your comments and I'm like oh I got so
many fans and I look and it's like this
is a fake ass account just liking my old
tweet from two years ago yeah hope you
guys enjoyed that episode of JK news
make sure to stay connected because
we're constantly updating our social
media so follow us at JK films for
Instagram and at JK films for Twitter to
watch more videos click right over here
[Music]